welcome to the live stream good to be
back it has been I guess it's been a
week to the day since the last
livestream what has happened in the last
week number one I went to and already
came back from Las Vegas where I
broadcast from a conference Mike
Papantonio s conference is a legal
conference and I saw Sam cedar and I saw
gen Kyogre and I saw a whole bunch of
progressive media people that was good
already made it back told some very
interesting stories one relating to
David Blaine and rape and another
relating to kind of a weird I guess I'd
call it a safety related incident on my
flight home from Las Vegas both of those
stories on today's bonus show and you
can check that out if you are a member
or patron both very very good stories we
also since the last time I live-streamed
have achieved and surpassed the 400
thousand subscriber mark on YouTube and
thanks first of all number one but that
is a big accomplishment for us I
mentioned this on the regular show today
but the first month of our YouTube
channel we had 777 views the entire
month we had 777 views and now we
average anywhere from 7 to 12 million
views per month on the YouTube channel
so it has become such a huge platform
for us and it really started kind of on
a whim
in fact I mentioned Genki ago from The
Young Turks back in 2000 I guess I must
have been up the summer of 2009 I met
jank at a radio conference in New York
City and he said I think this YouTube
thing could be big I would suggest just
film the radio show and podcast that
you're doing and just put it on YouTube
and see what happens
and obviously I'm glad I did now that
it's such a huge platform for us both
for live-streaming and for the Regular
Show content and everything else so
thank you to the four hundred
thousand-plus of you
who have helped us get to 400,000
subscribers that is absolutely huge for
us and we're actually going to be doing
I mention this again on the regular
broadcast show today and there will be a
YouTube clip publishing at some point
not exactly sure when this Friday we are
going to have a 400,000 related
membership special that will go out to
everybody who's on our newsletter list
then you can get on that at david
pakman.com right side of the website you
just type in your name where it says
stay in the know I think it is
and then on Friday you'll get an email
which will tell you how to take
advantage of a 400,000 related
membership specials so all very exciting
things and we're gonna get into the the
political talk here momentarily I'll be
taking your questions if this is your
first live stream welcome and it is it
is really live unless it's not if you're
watching a replay then it is not live
but that aside live streams are live
which is very exciting and as a result
of that you can ask questions you can
send comments I will read them I will
answer your questions and respond to
your comments two ways to do it number
one use the dollar sign at the bottom of
the chat window which is YouTube's super
chat you can ask a question I'll read it
and respond you can make a comment I
will read it and react
you can also circumvent YouTube super
chat fee which I believe is 30% by going
to stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show link to that
in the video description you can still
ask questions you can still make
comments but you do not have that 30%
YouTube super chat fee so that's a
really great thing and then of course
new members and patrons will get live
thank-yous and shout outs during the
live stream we are starting the evening
at 1951 patrons when we get to 2,500 I
will be recording editing and uploading
my Boston College lectures I'm teaching
a class at Boston College the semester
number of people hundreds of you have
expressed an interest in us producing
those lectures for YouTube they're about
75 minutes each there's about a dozen of
them and when we gets a lot of work but
when we get to 2500 patrons we'll do
that we're at 1951 right now and it'd be
great to get to 1975 tonight if we get
to 1975 this evening I'll create and
release a 55 percent member
discount code and then of course if you
don't want to wait for that there's a
40% membership discount code already
available at david pakman.com slash
membership and anybody who signs up
again during the stream I will thank you
I will sing your praises extensively
during the stream and I think that that
will be a very very important thing for
all of us so thank you in advance and
we'll get to that so there's been this
back-and-forth over Donald Trump's
conversation on the phone with Army
Widow
goldstar Widow Myesha Johnson and she is
the widow of 'la David Johnson who was
tragically killed in Nazaire and the
controversy started around just as
Donald Trump even going to talk about it
is even going to react to this and only
when the media heat became significant
did Donald Trump comment on it and then
soon thereafter we heard from my Isha
Johnson as well as congresswoman
Frederica Wilson that Donald Trump
lacked total empathy during the phone
call that he reportedly said something
along the lines of well I'm sure your
husband knew what he was getting himself
into I'm paraphrasing when he was
serving and there were questions as to
whether Frederica Wilson was telling the
truth in terms of her characterization
of this phone call with Donald Trump or
not well Donald Trump has called it fake
news but we've now heard from Maya
Johnson she was interviewed this morning
I think she did a couple of interviews
actually but the one will be playing
clips from tomorrow is from Good Morning
America with George Stephanopoulos where
she effectively said Frederica Wilson's
characterization of my phone call with
Donald Trump was 100% correct
and I was thinking when I saw the
interview okay well Trump's not going to
get into a Twitter war with a Goldstar
Widow is he and of course why wouldn't
he he criticized a gold star dad because
your con why wouldn't he start calling a
gold star widow effectively a liar and
indeed he did with in something like I
think it was a half hour I don't I'm
just going off the top of my head
gonna do the full story tomorrow within
roughly a half hour of Myesha Johnson
saying yeah
what Frederica Wilson said is true
Donald Trump took to Twitter basically
countering the characterization of
Goldstar Widow Myesha Johnson saying
that he knew the deceased soldiers name
and you know whatever else it was that
he said and my immediate reaction was
how do you win a media fight with a
Goldstar Widow this is self-inflicted
damage and the only the only thing you
know people say Trump's playing for DHS
the guy is a master the only way that
you could convince me that what he is
doing makes any sense at all is if it's
misdirection to take attention away from
horrible stuff that he's doing and I
know he's trying to do horrible stuff
one of those things by the way is
allowing the mandatory recall of retired
Air Force pilots which we're going to
get to it's a whole other story and
we're gonna get to that tomorrow but
unless there is something absolutely
major that Donald Trump is attempting to
take attention away from I don't know
how you win a media fight against the
gold star a gold star Widow and if
somebody in Super Chad or through stream
labs wants to explain to me what the win
is here how do even right-wingers
support Donald Trump picking this fight
with with a woman who is presumably at
the high point of her grief here she
went to the funeral of her now deceased
husband Lou David Johnson on Saturday
meanwhile Donald Trump was playing golf
spending something like I think the 74th
day during his as yet short-lived
presidency the 74th day playing golf and
it is he who is picking a fight with
this gold star widow and his exact quote
let me pull up his tweet I do have it
here within a half hour of this
interview that my you should
and did he he tweeted I had a very
respectful conversation with the widow
of Sergeant Lee David Johnson and spoke
his name from beginning without
hesitation the other story we did today
that relates to this is that we had
Sarah Huckabee Sanders the White House
press secretary saying there is no
transcript of that phone call with my
Isha Johnson meanwhile you have lara
trump who is the wife of trump son Eric
trump saying on fox news that she read
the transcript and there's a full
youtube clip up about that I won't
repeat that story there is no transcript
I read the transcript how could both
possibly be true in what universe could
both of those statements possibly be
true and it's just more lying and who is
really you know the news is not the
lying anymore and I've spoken about the
need for media particularly progressive
independent media to really pick and
choose which abrasive and scandalous
Trump stories to report on because the
reality is when everything is a scandal
nothing is a scandal and that that means
we have to pick and choose and you know
Trump lying the Trump family lying is
not exactly news right now but the
persistent and constant disrespect of
the military absolutely is a story here
and that's what I'm hearing from people
and you know that the right likes to say
that they have the sort of monopoly or
they don't like to say it they believe
that they have the monopoly on
patriotism and pointing out when someone
isn't supporting the troops typically
Democrats I've said it for years
supporting the troops is not putting a
yellow ribbon on your car it's just not
and the reality is that supporting the
troops means to me not sending the
troops into battle unless it absolutely
is necessary to maintain our
national security sending troops into
battle for political gain for natural
resources whatever that is not
supporting the truth to me blindly
defending whatever mission the president
assigns to the troops that's also not
supporting the troops saying that X or Y
statement is disrespect to the troops as
if the troops are some singular entity
what am i referring to I'm referring to
the flag controversy that's also not
being supportive of the troops and it's
truly disgusting what we are seeing here
time and again from Donald Trump and
from the right and I you know I'm
everyday I am seeing new lows here and
it's absolutely and totally disgusting
okay very quickly I want to address this
before we get into some of the other
political news that's going on I've
already seen a couple messages in the
chat and a couple people have asked why
isn't David covering the Clinton Russia
uranium story it's a major scandal and
it's terrible for Democrats and David is
refusing to cover it I hate to break it
to you but the Russia Clinton uranium
story is number one very much lacking in
evidence a lot of it has to do with
Russian racketeering involving American
nuclear companies and a lot of the
recent reporting doesn't really present
much new evidence of anything so I know
that there's this idea that I won't
cover stories that make Democrats look
bad the truth is I cover those stories
all the time and I've been hugely
critical of Democrats for years I've
criticized both of the micro and macro
levels so much of what Democrats are
doing I have no reason whatsoever
particularly since I'm not a Democrat
and I'm completely against the
corporatist takeover of the Democratic
Party that we've seen over the last
fifteen to twenty years I have no
particular reason to defend Democrats
I've never been a Democrat and I'm not
married to the idea of the two-party
system in fact I think it's destructive
so if you're looking for that story
there are plan
d of media outlets where you can find it
traditional and non-traditional
conspiratorial media outlets where you
can see that I don't believe that that
is a major story in any way shape or
form if I'm wrong prove me wrong explain
to me why it's a major story ok let me
get to a couple of the other stories
that I am going to be talking about
tomorrow actually before I even do that
let me mention the what's going on with
the calendar so for the last few years I
guess three years we have done a David
Pakman show calendar 2015 2016 and 2017
the first two calendars were hatred mail
themed last years or I guess this year's
which was available at the end of 2016
was a comic book styled calendar with
comics show related comics from Dan
Burke people have started asking me
David are you doing a 2018 calendar and
to be perfectly honest I hadn't planned
on it because we've been so busy
particularly dealing with the fallout
from YouTube ad pocalypse and D
monetization but I am completely open
completely open to doing a 20-18
calendar the thing is we need art it's
always been audience submitted art
either Dan Burke the cartoonist who did
last year's entire calendar or audience
hatred mail related images so I need
your submissions we need 12 images for
the 12 months as well as a cover so
these need to be 1920 by 1080 resolution
you send them in and we will make a
calendar if we get those 13 images and
if this is interesting to you by all
means help help us out because I just I
could not be less artistically skilled I
really couldn't it's an absolute and
total disaster
so I unfortunately can't contribute
anything to the calendar other than the
logistics of putting it together but
we're open to doing a 20-18 calendar and
really we need to get it done by I
always want to make it available before
Thanksgiving so we have roughly a month
to get this done I think this is enough
time but it is it is up to you the power
is with you
and I'll follow up on that when we have
some news and we do have a video clip
coming out about that that will go into
more detail about this okay
on the program tomorrow I am going to be
discussing this amazing video of John
McCain just crushing Peter Doocy
and if Peter Ducey's name sounds
familiar his dad Steve Doocy
is one of the least informed and most
boneheaded Fox News hosts out there and
presumably by nepotism primarily Peter
Doocy also does reporting for Fox News
and this clip is amazing we're gonna
play tomorrow a Peter Doocy asked John
McCain because John McCain is having
more and more of a conflict but Donald
Trump and rightly so I should add Peter
Doocy asked John McCain are you going to
now just obstruct anything Trump
proposes because you're having a
personal disagreement with him and John
McCain looks at Peter Doocy like he's an
idiot which he is and says why would you
ask why would you say something that's
stupid that's a really really dumb
question and I don't know as I mentioned
today on the program I don't know if
John McCain is letting it all hang out
so to speak because of this horribly
tragic brain cancer diagnosis that he
received if it's because he believes
that Donald Trump represents the total
jumping the shark of the Republican
Party I couldn't tell you why I really
couldn't tell you why it is that John
McCain is is just saying what he thinks
at this point but I like it and I'm not
defending John McCain's politics I don't
you know it's very easy to compare to
Trump lots of right-wingers start to
seem reasonable
I'm not romanticizing in any way John
McCain but I like the fact that he's I
guess calling it like he sees it and
this clip tomorrow I think you're really
gonna like this clip it's it's really
quite good also tomorrow I'm going to be
interviewing Abigail Marsh Abigail Marsh
is an expert on child psychopathy and
this is something I've read quite a bit
about not because I was considered to be
a child psychopath by the way just in
case you were wondering but I've read a
number of long-form pieces about it and
she has done a lot of work
into if you identify signs of
psychopathy very early in kids can you I
don't think cure is the right word but
can you functionally eliminate the
problems that psychopathy can cause
these problems the right word I don't
even know can you ameliorate the
symptoms of psychopathy I'm sort of
searching for words here but that's
gonna be an interview tomorrow with
Abigail Marsh which I'm really really
looking forward to if you have questions
for her absolutely send them in via
super chat or via stream labs on
Wednesday I'm gonna be interviewing
Scott page he has a book called the
diversity bonus and in that book he
argues that companies should diversify
in terms of ethnic and racial background
in terms of sexual orientation in many
different ways not because of a morality
issue but because he believes there is
actually a business side advantage to
diversity so I'll be interviewing Scott
page on Wednesday and then Thursday this
is just a major week and kudos to
producer Pat for having booked all of
these interviews Thursday I'll be
interviewing Neil Howe and that's not a
name you might recognize but he is a
major player in what's going on right
now in the Trump administration because
former chief white house propagandist
Steven Bannon is a big advocate of what
is called Straus how generational theory
okay google it if you've not heard of it
and that informs Steve bannon's
worldview which was a big part in
informing Donald Trump's perspective on
politics to the extent that he has any
perspective and mostly it's do whatever
someone told him five minutes ago and
Neil Howe as the name suggests is how
from skräuss how generational theory
google it it is fascinating and I am
really looking forward to speaking to
him so a lot of really really good
interviews coming up this week and
I look forward to doing them and we're
already working on great interviews for
next week okay let me do a couple thank
you so I don't fall behind on this I
mentioned at the top of the livestream
that anybody anybody who signs up for a
David Pakman show membership during the
live stream will get a thank you from me
and a couple of people have done exactly
that what I would do if I became a
member today was immediately watch or
listen to today's bonus show because
over the weekend I was in Las Vegas at a
conference I had two really really great
stories oh and thanks gigantic for the
contribution we have the zombie
animation today happening for Super
chats I believe or stream lapse
contributions over the weekend I was in
Las Vegas and the entertainment at the
conference I was at was David Blaine and
I have a rape related David Blaine story
that I tell on today's bonus show I also
have an interesting story and we have a
lot of commercial pilots in our audience
I have an interesting story involving a
major US airline and what I would
consider to be a moderate safety issue
on my flight back from Las Vegas on
Saturday and I tell that story on the
bonus show and I really want feedback
from people on that story so if you do
become a member or if you're already a
member
check out the October 23rd bonus show
because it is a doozy in any case thank
you to Patti
Goodall Patti Goodall is a brand-new
david pakman show member Thank You Patti
you're a great person and also thank you
to Christina Hasselblad Christina has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership she is opted to use the
coupon code
I voted 17 which saves you 40% off of
membership 40% off of membership you can
use the coupon code I voted 17 and the
bonus show just one of many many many
many member benefits okay let me get to
our first stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show contribution
actually before I even do that I been
meaning to do this I don't know if Jacob
ball
is on today's livestream Jacob is a
regular on the live streams last
livestream which was a week ago Eric
Patterson made a major contribution
through super chat of $99 and he
challenged someone to beat that
contribution and Jacob ball did with a
$99 and one cent contribution and then
Eric Patterson made a hundred dollar
contribution and at the time that I
signed off from the livestream that
hundred dollar contribution was the high
modern high watermark for the night and
just as I ended the stream Jacob ball
came in with what I believe was $100 and
one cent contribution again besting Eric
Patterson and I had just disconnected
and it's been an entire week and it's
been weighing on my conscience for a
full week so Jacob if you're here I did
see that you had the biggest
contribution last Monday Eric you got
you got bested I don't know what else to
say I won't say you were cooked because
I don't think it applies here
but you were bested by Jacob ball and
thanks Jacob I did see the contribution
and I really really do appreciate that
okay let's get to today's first
contribution $5.00 at stream last comm
slash the david pakman show from
gigantic haven't seen your Josh Zepps
interview yet and really excited I have
any number of feelings about it nice to
get an Aussie on the show also please
fill the discord yeah so there is a
discord server for the David Pakman show
you can find the details of it on our
reddit at david pakman.com slash read it
there was recently a debate between
David Pakman show
redditors and sargon of akkad or I call
them Carl Benjamin redditors and I
believe upcoming there is a secular talk
debate where David Pakman show redditors
are going to be debating followers of
the Kyle kolinsky secular talk reddit so
a lot of really really good stuff going
on so yes the discord is happening and
yes I did interview Josh Zepps
today on the David Pakman show
it is going to be publishing this
standalone interview will publish to
YouTube let me take a look at when
that's happening Oh actually so
the standalone interview isn't
publishing until Friday David Pakman
show members and patrons at the five
dollar-a-month level can already check
out that interview because they get the
full broadcast show every single day so
check that out Josh Zepps really good
interview and I want to make a I'm gonna
pre announce an upcoming announcement
which is that Josh Zepps has been
generous in inviting me to his podcasts
now that Josh Zepps podcast has had some
major major guests on it and josh has
been kind enough to invite me some of
the guests that he has had on his
program include who are they I'm not
finding the list right now
but believe me folks trust me most
people don't know this but Josh Zepps
has had some really good guests and I
might be on his program as early as this
week so really really great interview
I'm looking forward to being on Josh
Zepps program and that is very very
exciting stuff I do want to issue one
more thank you we have a new patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
Natalie Romer Natalie Romer has pledged
two dollars a month at patreon.com slash
David Pakman show Natalie thank you and
that really wasn't too painful was it
and I've said this before that then the
numbers are actually quite staggering as
I mentioned at the top of the show we
are past week and thank you a donation
from from my girlfriend apparently we
have surpassed four hundred thousand
subscribers on YouTube okay we have
nineteen hundred and fifty two patrons
that means that only point four eight
percent of our YouTube audience is
contributing at patreon.com slash david
pakman show if we could just get to two
percent if we could get to two percent
of our
YouTube audience contributing on patreon
which would be 8,000 patrons I would
never ever ever ever ever have to talk
about the off a cliff problems that we
are having with revenue on the YouTube
channel as a result of D monetization
because the problem would be over we
need only get to about 2% support and it
is over folks so thanks to Natalie for
the contribution really really
appreciate it and I will keep doing the
thank-yous and before I get too far I
also want to send a thank you to Dana
Lee Dana Lee has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership using opting
not to use the 40% discount code I voted
17 but still very much appreciate it in
fact maybe more appreciated because
she's contributing the full six bucks a
month and she will get access to two
major stories on today's bonus show one
which I am calling the David Blaine rape
story from the weekend and the other
which I am calling the major US airline
flight safety story okay so two very
very good stories on today's bonus show
I don't know if anybody can hear that
but it sounds like my upstairs neighbors
are bowling I didn't know that they had
installed the bowling alley upstairs but
I believe that they are bowling right
now okay Anke Bing G 2000 has sent a $10
super chat question is making videos
about people like Alex Jones it's stefan
molyneux Gavin McInnes and so on
pointing out the ridiculousness worth it
or is it counterproductive very good
question the answer is it depends I
don't think that a show just based on
critiquing what conspiracy theorists and
other right-wingers like Alex Jones
Stefan Molyneux and Gavin McInnes say I
don't think that that alone is a
worthwhile program I think that we need
to be doing proactive stories the way we
do what we say let us lay out illegal
immigration for the next 30 minutes for
you let
lay out you know whatever I do believe
though that pretending the ideas of
people like Alex Jones and these others
don't exist I don't think that that's a
good idea either because it furthers the
sort of echo chamber and filter bubble
ideas and because of the social media
algorithms that exist right now even if
you think that you're getting a diverse
diverse set of ideas because you're on
Facebook and you read recommended
articles or you do Google searches or
whatever all of those searches
everything that's being displayed is
tailored to you already by algorithms on
those networks and platforms so I do
believe that there is value to reminding
people particularly people who might
already be in line with us in terms of
ideology that these ideas exist ignoring
them will not actually make them go away
and it can actually provide cover for
really bad ideas to become law so I
think that balance balance is the key
okay excuse me a user named David's
girlfriend who of course is not actually
my girlfriend sent a dollar contribution
at stream labs.com
slash the david packard show saying hi
David it's lovely seeing you live stream
I'd really like to do a duo stream
sometime the fans will love it also did
you see that video where sexual
fantasies about you and Jiang huger were
narrated this gigantic guy is a real
piece of work huh yeah so listen there
was a fan fiction done of me and gent
youger involved in highly sexual
circumstances several years ago somebody
wrote it it was just a written piece and
I don't know how it came back out of the
woodwork a few days ago and now it has
been done as a full narration and it's
on our reddit discussion forum what if I
can find it real quick it's so tough to
find stuff on that reddit discussion
forum let's see if I search for jank
maybe it will come up man I'm not
finding it here see if I sort by new Wow
yeah I'm not I'm not finding it but
believe me it's available on our reddit
discussion for
david pakman.com slash read it I did see
it I found it funny and it's clever you
know so yeah check it out if you're into
that type of thing I guess okay our next
super chat comes from Jamal Swift with a
ten dollar super chat what do you think
of Kelly's women used to be sacred
statement women used to be sacred I have
not seen that statement John Kelly is
sad women are no longer sacred women are
not that sad says the Huffington Post
John Kelly White House chief of staff
made a comment during a news conference
that focused on Trump's bungled phone
call to the widow of a slain soldier
Kelly lamented that unlike in the good
old days something that some things are
no longer get respect like gold star
families religion and women when I was a
kid growing up a lot of things were
sacred in our country women were sacred
and looked upon with great honor that's
obviously not the case anymore as we see
from recent cases I don't know what he's
talking about I mean the the the level
of commentary that we get from trump
staffers is often completely
unintelligible so I don't know what he's
talking about but I will research it
more Jamal and follow up if I think it's
necessary Juan Garcia sent a $2 super
chat romantic marry reject oh I guess
this is like the politically correct
version of eff marry kill Beyonce
Rihanna or Shakira romantic marry and
reject I think that from those three I
would marry Shakira I would marry
Shakira I don't I mean I guess my
instinct is that she would be sort of
closest to the cultural background that
I'm used to being South America and
although Argentinean and Colombian
culture are pretty damn different but
anyway yeah Shakira she seems like the
the the best one to hang around for long
periods of time I would probably be
romantic with Beyonce and reject Rihanna
if that's what I had to do okay and
another super shot from Quan Garcia two
dollars where would you rank Trump
presidents listen there's two answers to
that one one is it's what you know you
can't really rank a president while they
are still president you'd really need to
get some separation from their
presidency in order to to be able to
more precisely assess their performance
as president however there's nothing
common about Trump's presidency and I
think that I am very confident saying
that the first what is it October 23rd
so we are just over nine months in I
think it's pretty clear that the first
nine months of Trump's presidency have
been one of the biggest unmitigated and
total abortions of of early presidencies
I mean can you think of a bigger
bungling and total incompetence during
the first nine months of a presidency
and again this I am NOT romanticizing
george w bush I think it's really
dangerous to normalize george w bush by
pointing out that things were way less
crazy when george w bush was president
and under donald trump but the george w
bush presidency I disagreed with the guy
on policy and I thought he was not
equipped for the job but it was nothing
it was nothing compared to what we are
seeing now
under President Donald Trump so I think
that we need to wait to see what the
full damage is of the Trump presidency
to really make a total assessment but
I'm pretty comfortable already saying
it's bad it's bad and I you know I don't
know what else I can add to that a
couple of questions in the regular chat
about the race and IQ video the race and
IQ video is one that we've been working
on for a while and I know I've been
teasing it for a while we are doing a
long-form investigation and I'm actually
going to pull up the notes for it right
now just so I can have them in front of
me we've been talking about doing a
long-form race and IQ the connection
between race and IQ video since
basically Sam Harris's controversial
podcast with Murray the author of the
bell curve and the reason it hasn't yet
been published is we really want to get
it
right and there are so many angles to it
such that producer Noah and I have been
going over it and moving things around
shortening adding removing we had one of
our viewers who is very well-versed in
this issue review the entire script in
order to give us feedback as far as what
it is that that we should include and
shouldn't include so it's coming it's
coming and it's going to be very very
good it's going to be a really really
good piece and we're going to address
not only the merit not we're going to
address not only the data of race and IQ
but also what it would mean what IQ even
measures it's going to be one of the
better long-form pieces that we've done
so stay tuned for that really really
good piece coming up okay let's go to
our next super chat from engi binky mm
who sent a $10 super chat thanks so much
TYT had a video about nu radiation
regulations citing a bloomberg article
yesterday Thunderfoot and Jeff Holliday
had responses to it are you familiar
with it no nu radiation regulations
let's see what that says if I do a
Google News search EPA says higher
radiation levels pose no harmful threat
of harmful health effect okay let me
book market right now and review and
this is great you guys are helping me
plan tomorrow's program I'm gonna drop a
link to that into tomorrow's list of
possible stories along with the reality
that American life expectancy is
declining by the way not sure if you
heard that story I'll check that out but
I'm not familiar with that offhand
engi bengi we also have a couple new
stream labs contributions stream labs
comm slash the david pakman show jay-z
has sent a $4 contribution David stay
away from Beyonce there is no way that
she can resist your rugged argentinian
charm I feel the same way jay-z very
very good point
Christina has sent a dollar contribution
did you title the colors of your David
Pakman show t-shirts
I enjoyed the names
of the selections yeah so what Christina
is referring to is that if you go to
david pakman.com slash gear you will see
that the t-shirts and hoodies and
everything else and by the way there are
numerous numerous different styles
available and crew including hatred mail
themes and so many others the colors
have some interesting names including
camel cantaloupe you say cantaloupe or
cantaloupe I've always said cantaloupe
charcoal Moss earth pomegranate
I chose none of those names there are
our apparel manufacturer who is based in
Ohio all the printing is done right here
in the United States on 100% recycled
fabric they chose the color names
Christina I'm just quite frankly not
that creative so no I did not choose
those names Christina with another
dollar question how often are you
recognized from the show you know it's
happening more and more often and I get
very uncomfortable whenever it happens I
was just in Las Vegas
Tuesday through Saturday and this
conference I go to it's all right on the
Las Vegas Strip and I find it very
corporate and stuffy and I want to get
out of these huge casinos where smoking
is still allowed in the casino area and
you don't see daylight for you can
really go the entire day without seeing
natural light so I will always hop in an
uber or actually I use lyft for
political reasons and go to old Las
Vegas or to the Arts District or
wherever and I was at a great coffee
shop of total hipster coffee shop that I
really like in Las Vegas and I grabbed
my coffee and turned around and someone
said hey are you David and I said yes I
am and I was recognized right there in
the middle of Las Vegas it happens I
would say probably once a week at this
point somewhere and sometimes I
recognize that I'm being recognized but
the person won't always come up and talk
to me but people are kind of loud so I
can often hear what they're saying to
whoever they're with but yeah it's
happening about once a week and I'm
always a little bit scared and I always
kind of stay back when I'm sure
because I'm worried someone's gonna
punch me in the face and that wouldn't
be good that wouldn't be good
extreme hey treats story has sent a $4
stream lab comm contribution you can do
that at stream labs comm slash the David
Pakman show
David on the show you mentioned that
you've had to forward extreme hatred
mail to the cops
I didn't say cops I did not say cops I
would say it is I forward it to federal
contacts that I have not cops has this
ever resulted in anyone's imprisonment
what is the most extreme thing that has
ever happened due to hey tree Emil you
know I'm not sure that I should really
answer that I'm not sure that that's
something I should really delve into
what I can tell you is I don't know for
sure whether hate mail I've received has
ever led to imprisonment and that's the
honest truth but I don't know that it's
really good to talk about that because I
don't want to give any attention to
those who might think it's clever to do
something or say something or anything
like that
James has sent a $2.00 stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show contribution
how would a $15.00 national minimum wage
be more effective than the minimum wage
increases in Seattle average workers had
made a hundred and twenty five dollars
less each month there you know James I
don't know exactly what you're referring
to I've not seen the data you're
referring to so I don't know exactly how
to answer that but you know I would
point you to some we've done a number of
recent minimum wage related videos and I
would encourage you to check some of
those out it sounds like you might sort
of believe some of the debunked talking
points around the minimum wage so maybe
check that out but I'm not sure how else
to answer that story gigantic has sent a
dollar stream Labs contribution also
congratulations on 400,000 subscribers
yeah we have surpassed four hundred
thousand subscribers on our YouTube
channel I mentioned this at the
beginning of the stream I will mention
it again in September of 2009 when our
Channel star
we had under 800 views the entire month
we now average 5 to 15,000 new
subscribers per month and 7 to 12
million views per month which is
incredible and I only have the 400,000
plus people that are in our audience to
thank and yes we are beyond 400,000
subscribers Friday we will be doing a
mass email to everybody on our
newsletter who signs up for our
newsletter you will get a coupon code
for a huge membership discount that will
be related to the 400,000 subscriber
theme so if you want to get in on that
you can just sign up for our newsletter
at david pakman.com and i do have a
couple other new members to thank Nathan
Ross has signed up during the live
stream Leslie Henson and Robert elephant
all have signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership just what we've been
chatting here which is really really
great stuff thank you to all of you and
we've got a big big membership discount
coming up on Friday sort of in honor of
or to celebrate 400,000 subscribers
let's get to a couple other super chats
juan garcia has sent a $10 super chat as
the best progressive youtube hosts
please debate and crush ben shapiro he
often talks smack about the left saying
we're violent our policies are bad
despite the economy doing better under
democrats I've said it before I'll say
it again number one I had been Shapiro
on the program we email every I don't
know maybe like once a year we'll email
a couple times I would be glad to have
him on and debate him or to be on his
program
the only thing would be it needs to be a
specific debate about a particular issue
and a lot of times it's not clear what
issue it should be and it should be an
issue that resonates with both of us and
is sort of relevant not only to us but
to the audiences but I'm willing to do
it a user by the name of Who Framed
Robert Picardo
has sent a $2.00 super chat the Orville
or Star Trek discovery I don't even know
what the Orville is I mean Google that
oh the Orville is an American comedy
series you know I don't watch Star Trek
and I don't
watch the Orville but I see that the
Orville is a comedy I'm not that into
comedies I'm more into dramas and
particularly dark ones so I guess I
would say even though Star Trek isn't
really dark Star Trek Discovery engi
binky 22000 has sent a five-dollar super
chat I recommend looking at the
Thunderfoot video about the new
radiation levels it's his area of
expertise I will two-dollar super chat
in Spanish from a user going by the name
show soy Bob also who says DeWitt grace
given Keith's dad a Twitter the Trump I
think what he means and this might be a
translate.google.com translation should
Trump's twit I don't know if you're
asking what or whether Trump's Twitter
should be removed from the internet or
whether whether Twitter should be taken
from Donald Trump in other words not
allowing him to tweet no I think Trump
should be allowed to tweet because it's
absolutely fantastic and I don't believe
that Donald Trump's Twitter account
should be taken down but I do believe
that Donald Trump deleting tweets is
arguably a violation of the presidential
Records Act because these are
declarations from the President of the
United States so I I believe that Donald
Trump deleting tweets is potentially
problematic and while we're doing the
Spanish messages we have a $1 stream
labs contribution from a user going by
know via the beat which just means
David's girlfriend in Spanish and this
happens to be the same user who
regularly translates stuff into Spanish
using Google Translate and ask me the
questions it's very very awkwardly
translated usually but let's give it a
shot and it's very difficult to read
these okay that to fans look at geerdon
it's I mean what he means is give your
fans what they want but it's a totally
bogus translation and he goes on to say
un segment oh and espanol meaning a
segment in Spanish so Lona only one kiss
a boy Joshua Ricardo command daddy of
politico's maybe I can help with the
political commentaries cuando live
stream de cocina
missing a word or two there but the
question is when will you do a cooking
livestream one the livestream and show
and twitch when will you livestream the
show on Twitch violet takedo mucho xx2
novia meaning okay I love you very much
xx I don't remember if the X is hugs or
kisses your girlfriend is this funny to
anyone are these bizarrely translated
Spanish super chats funny to anyone cuz
I don't find them that funny I find them
ridiculous but they're not particularly
funny to me David Moss has sent a $2.00
stream lapse contribution when labeling
yourself as a progressive how do you
challenge yourself to not be swooned
into tribalism listen I think that I do
a couple thin things number one I am
more worried about tribalism in terms of
political parties then in terms of just
identifying as progressive but I've done
a video on this already a long-form
video where I say you know the label
that I use is maybe the most appropriate
label to communicate to other what my
general political views are but I would
much prefer to just talk about
particular issues and say here's where I
am on this issue and it can be
characterized however you want but let's
discuss the merits of the issue and
actually try to make good arguments and
identify flaws in each other's arguments
to better our understanding so yeah I
mean I I label myself as a progressive
because I think it's the most accurate
term right now to communicate my general
view to others but I agree with what
you're saying which is anytime that you
start identifying with labels you can
get away from focusing on issues and I
think issues are the most of most
important things for us to focus on okay
we've got three or four more of these
questions but I do want to take just a
brief pause from this just to point out
something we're doing because I
mentioned it very briefly at the
beginning of the livestream and not set
not since
we have started a patreon page to allow
people who maybe don't have five or ten
dollars a month to contribute to be able
to contribute something to the
production of the show because the
production of the show does incur
significant cost we have staff we have
connectivity issues we pay rent at a
studio this is not happening out of my
mom's basement despite what many hey
tree it's like to say and one of the
things that I've expressed an interest
in doing is taking the lectures that
I've done at Boston College I am adjunct
professor of communication at Boston
College this semester I'm teaching a
class on media literacy and epistemology
and critical thinking and talk media and
I've offered to take my long-form
lectures which are about 75 minutes each
there's about a dozen of them and turn
them into YouTube videos and when I
mentioned this we got so many emails
from people saying David please do it
I've never gone to college and would
love to see what your class is like or
this sounds like something I would
really enjoy whatever and it's really a
lot of work so what we've done in order
to try to piggyback on that and grow the
financial support for the show is
established a 2,500 patron goal when we
get to 2500 patrons and we're about 80%
of the way there when we get to 2500
patrons we will go through the work we
will do the work as I like to say of
producing editing and releasing those
dozen long-form lectures they will first
be made available to our patrons since
they are making this possible but then
because I believe that this this
information and lessons should be
available to everybody the dozen
lectures will be available to everybody
on YouTube so I like it if people made
some contributions to patreon today and
I will thank every single one of you and
this is totally it's totally what am I
trying to say it is an it's an issue of
each patron counts as one vote one step
towards 2500 regardless of how much you
can contribute so if you can contribute
a hundred or 500 bucks a month by all
means we need the money and I will
welcome it but we're looking for 2500
patrons so a contribution of $1 a month
gets us just as much closer to the goal
as a contribution of 10 50 or $100 a
month so please make those contributions
I would really like it if we were able
to get to 1975 1975 is the patron target
that I've established for tonight and if
we do that I'll create and release to
you a 55 percent membership discount
code we're we're only at 1952 we've only
had one new patreon contribution so far
it really does bum me out when we don't
make progress on that and I want to
propose something else to you I would be
willing if everybody thinks it would be
interesting I would be willing to set up
something in the background for these
live streams where maybe I'm stacking
Jenga tiles and every time we get a
contribution via patreon I add one and
whatever number of tiles I'm able to
stack we create before they fall I
create a discount code for that
percentage I don't know I'm willing to
think of other things and some of them
might be gimmicky or something some of
them might be kind of entertaining
another possibility would be and this is
just an idea I've got a fidget spinner
here and maybe when I spin it we come up
with I don't know people bet on the
number of seconds that it will spin on
its own by making patreon contributions
of a particular amount and whoever is
closest as this thing is slowing down
I think the bearing on this one might be
messed up because I dropped it a bunch
of times maybe they get a free
membership I don't know anyway I'm
willing to think of different ideas but
by all means please do get those
contributions in 2500 will be a really
big deal for us in terms of what it will
represent as far as financial financial
support but more importantly it will
lead us to create and release a dozen
long-form lectures on critical thinking
and media literacy and epistemology okay
let me get back to Super chats and
stream labs contributions the real tuba
tier has sent a $10 super chat what are
your thoughts about
Walker and other politics in Wisconsin
many of us are scared of the vanishing
pension Act that's been going on I do
not envy Wisconsin residents you have
been crushed for at this point what 8
years more and I you know it's very easy
when you live somewhere else to just say
hey move somewhere else but the truth is
people are rooted where they live they
are they're mostly for a reason they
have family they have jobs whatever else
the case may be
and it's it's not reasonable to say hey
just get out just go somewhere else or
move and I genuinely feel terrible
terrible what is for what's going on in
Wisconsin and we're gonna cover the
vanishing pension pension Act
Alexander Birdmen has sent the ten
dollar super chat saying how it could
Trump pull off some Russian collusion
plot if he's barely capable of
completing a sentence the media acts
like the Russians have this master plot
to overthrow democracies and we do that
- here's the thing Alexander you don't
need Trump to be complicit to be
involved in the election of Trump and to
benefit from the election of Trump the
whole point is Trump is a puppet because
he's a [ __ ] and in fact if you were
Russia you're almost better off getting
Trump elected thinking that he got
himself elected merely on his merits and
political proposals and policy proposals
because then he is much more likely to
be manipulatable into doing what you
want if he doesn't think that it's
coming directly from you so I think
you're actually pointing I think his
incompetence is evidence that he is a
ripe target to be manipulated in exactly
the way that we suspect might have
happened
Steve Louis sent the five Canadian
dollar super chat loved your interview
with Frank Schaefer in 2015 I attended
LaBrie in Switzerland and can relate to
his life now still got to read his book
do not miss my interview with Francis
Schaeffer from a couple of years ago
very very interesting for sure
tune in dropout sent a ten-dollar super
chat have you seen the video of the
phone conversation with another gold
star widow Natasha de Alencar you can
view it on CNN politics just Google gold
Dhar widows full phone call with Trump I
haven't it's bookmarked and I plan to
look at it before tomorrow's show the
d2j bug has sent a 5 Canadian dollar
super check all your Smurfs are belong
to Smurfs ok I couldn't possibly comment
on that but I do appreciate the
contribution nonetheless a couple more
stream labs contributions Christina sent
a dollar contribution I was catching up
on the bonus show this morning and there
was a brief discussion of Pat being
kicked off a flight over an unsuitable
vegan meal have you ever had an incident
that got out of control in a similar way
well that was a joke Christina I hope
that the sarcasm was evident Pat was not
kicked off of a flight because of a
subpar vegan meal that he is admitted to
I've not really had incidents that got
out of control in a similar way but the
story I told from from my flight on
Saturday on today's bonus show is
dramatic nonetheless Blu has sent a
$2.00 stream labs.com contribution
asking do I follow Richard Wolf's show
economic update you know I really don't
follow the show but I get the summaries
of what's on the show on a regular basis
and Richard Wolfe was an economics
professor of mine at the University of
Massachusetts when I was an undergrad
and he's been he's one of the most
frequently appearing guests on the David
Pakman show and I am following his work
if not his program TDPS historian has
sent a $2.00 stream labs contribution
anthony Fantan Oh
deleted his this is the that is the plan
channel as a result we have lost the
video Pat's vegan birthday please get it
back it is an important part of TDPS
history you were right there was a
really good video made and I didn't know
that that channel has been deleted if
you can help me get it and I don't know
how it would be done if you can reach
out to someone if you can try to pull it
from the YouTube from a archived version
of the YouTube page although I don't
know if YouTube pages are archived in
that way get it to me I'll ask Anthony
for permission and try to get it
uploaded to our channel because we don't
want to lose that that is a
major creative piece of David Pakman
show history Christina sent the dollar
stream lapse contribution the Google
translated comment brought up a good
question when will you do cooking live
streams or videos what I have planned
and I just placed an order today what I
have planned is to coffee or it or as we
say cob feffy related videos where I am
going to be using both david pakman show
coffee blends one is an espresso blend
and one is a drip coffee blend to make
coffee in my kitchen
and I would be I would do it as a video
the the problem with live streaming it
is that it could go horribly wrong
the advantage to live streaming it is
that it could go horribly wrong that's
both the blessing and a curse maybe I
would live stream making coffee with
david pakman show coffee beans they'll
be coming i think they come in tomorrow
i ordered a couple bags from patrick
today so we will we will see if i can if
i can get that done gr has sent a $2.00
stream lapse contribution trumps
approval rating is in fact on the rise
Twilight Zone episodes are playing in
the background of an Escher illustration
that is sensibility Doug Jones y'all
holla at the DS word to gigantic smama
Frank macwrite Church homie love gr very
good you know I had missed G ours
super chats his unintellible
unintelligible super chat contributions
and he is now fully and pret and
efficiently transitioned over stream
labs and for that I think we can all be
very very grateful and on that note I
have to say a major major thank you to
Jamal who has just pledged $50 per month
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
Jamal
thank you that is absolutely absolutely
huge and I could not appreciate that
more join Jamal can you match Jamal with
just a dollar
I'm not saying match Jamal with $50 a
month but can you match Jamal by making
a con
you ssin of just a single dollar Jamal
can do 50 can you do a dollar most of
our audience from the surveys we've done
more than 90% can afford a dollar a
month
I don't need 90% of you to do it I only
need 2% 2% of our YouTube audience to
make a patreon pledge and it will solve
the financing woes of the David Pakman
show so that would be a big thing and on
that note thank you to Patrick stall
Smith Patrick stall Smith has signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership
using the discount code
I voted 17 which saved him 40% very much
appreciate that thank you so much we do
have a new super chat question it is
from alexander birdman for 2 bucks he
says the hills clinton uranium story
what are your thoughts talked about it
earlier on in the livestream alexander
there are reasons why i've not covered
it yet and i would say i don't want to
repeat it for people who open on the
entire stream but go back and check it
out because i did address that already
and on that note i've got to go make
dinner coffee live stream i'm thinking
about it
may be very very soon